what about John kazinski how does he do
in London he loves it but he went out
and bought himself a Tweed flat cap is
that good no he like something out of a
guy richy film you look great I think
Americans are so welcoming to British
people I do not think it works the other
way around John said that he would go
into this rather snooty Cafe near a flat
that I used to own there and he said
they're always so horrible to me in
there I went take your baseball capat
off cuz I just said you look so American
nobody wears baseball caps what does
that say about your country that like
well if you lose the baseball hat no one
wears baseball hats in England you look
so
American why don't you like us I have no
IA saved you in World War II
you